président ukrainien volodières réagit à
la situation à Mario Paul et au refus
des combattants de déposer les armes il
répond à nos confrères de France
Télévisions écoutez
les Russes nous ont posé cette ultimatum
en nous disant voici les conditions à
remplir et alors nous mettrons fin à la
guerre non ce n'est pas la façon de
procéder et cela ne dépend pas que de
moi
peut-être la question est que le pouvoir
et le peuple ont la même vision des
choses nous ne pouvons pas appliquer un
ultimatum
mais moi comment cela est-il possible ce
n'est pas faisable vous auriez à tous
nous détruire alors seulement
l'ultimatum pourrait être appliqué
des dates
ils disent donnez-nous vos villes Kiev
Mario Paul raquive mais ni les habitants
ni le président ne pourrait le faire
malheureusement
on le voit dans les villes qui sont
occupées lorsque les soldats russes les
pénètrent les gens ne se rendent pas
le drapeau ukrainien alors qu'est-ce que
vous voulez faire voulez-vous simplement
nous détruire tous et bien la seule
chose que je peux dire c'est que oui
l'ultimatum ne pourra être mise en œuvre
que lorsqu'il n'y aura plus personne